whether it's a date night guys night out
or quality time with dad libertine
social at mandalay bay has your tuesday
night plans covered and here to show us
on how to brush up on our cocktail
making skills is mix master mixologist
tony abu ganim how are you hey mercedes
good to see you i'm great see you i was
just telling you as i'm looking at the
setup that
making a cocktail it truly is an
artistry and you said something
interesting when i said how beautiful
everything looked what did you say well
that you taste with all your senses and
visual appearance and appeal is so
crucial in designing a cocktail take
this jeweler for instance i mean you
have the right beautiful silver julep
mug that gets all frosty on the outside
and that beautiful bonnet of mint on top
it's just absolutely it's a tree you're
right you see it and you're like i want
to drink that and you can actually teach
people how to make beautiful cocktails
that taste good tell us about your class
no absolutely mercedes it's like if i
give a woman a fish sheets for a day if
i teach a woman to fish she drinks
cocktails
so tonight at seven o'clock libertine
social
our kid bar in the back teaching a
whiskey class so we're going to learn to
make juleps we're going to learn to make
sours punch all these great whiskey
drinks including the old-fashioned that
you and i are going to make okay i've
always wanted to make an old-fashioned i
see my friends drinking them all the
time honestly i've never had one so this
is going to be my first the first all
right excited so how do we make an old
fashion well what you have here is you
have a mixing set so oh i'm actually
doing this oh my god you're doing this
this is very nerve-wracking i'm going to
get you over here and you're anyone who
attends tonight is going to get this
mixing set as part of the class so you
can make them at home cool this is gum
syrup which is a fancy name for
simple syrup or liquid sugar so all you
need is one bar spoon which is one
teaspoon which goes right into the
mixing glass okay very fancy i like it
next we add bitters
these are the tony abu ghanim not yet
world famous pecan chicory bitters are
you legit have your own bitters i have
my own veggies
did you say once one good uh dash yep
that's perfect okay and now we're going
to use a jim beam black label bourbon
whiskey this is a aged bourbon whiskey
up to eight years
86 proof
we're going to add two and a half ounces
don't be shy
that's one
small part of your [ __ ] and one large
part okay all right
tonight yay
there's one flipping over
what's the difference between whiskey
and bourbon well all bourbons are
whiskey
but bourbon whiskey is one of the most
regulated whiskies in the world
has to be made in america has to be made
from at least 51 percent corn can't be
distilled above 160 goes into the barrel
at 125 and ages to be straight for a
minimum of two years oh my gosh so it's
excitable all right you ready have you
stirred a cocktail before no okay just
it's real elegant
no it's not soup you're not
super sad
here fingers and just hear frank sinatra
playing in your head
my cousin helen david who taught me the
spirit drink said 20 times to the right
and 20 times to the left you do it so
much more elegantly than i do but this
is why you are the master mixologist and
i am your student today oh well okay 40
years um now we've got this beautiful
single cube of ice that's going to go in
your old-fashioned glass okay you're
going to put your julep strainer oh oh
you got it oh we got it yeah
and that's going to hold back the ice as
you pour it
in oh
you getting thirsty yeah this looks
really good
i'm excited all right now you want to
express the oils of this orange peel
okay over the top so just
just oh
just kind of get the essence of it yep
those beautiful oils okay i got a couple
filthy daniel black cherries for you oh
wow
oh
and we're done we're done we get to try
it best part you have to come oh this is
great cheers how do people get involved
in the classes well tonight again seven
o'clock liberty and social at mandalay
bay uh tickets are available at
eventbrite there's still a few left
love to see you there we have a lot of
fun starting you off with my welcome
whiskey punch and you'll be making
drinks just like mercedes and i did i uh
i'm a fan you i just found my new
favorite drink thank you
thank you send it over to you julian
your first old fashioned